[Music]
dating postmates sponsoring this episode
guys go download the post mates a views
cogent and Julian for $100 off free
delivery credit for your first seven
days welcome back to Jenny Jenny podcast
this episodes also brought to you by
stitch fix guys do you you sick of
shopping me to get stitch fix they shop
for you go to stitch fix calm slash
annejulien get 25% off when you keep
everything in your box also now
available in the UK that's the chick
slash annejulien or click link down
below also guys farmers dog your pets
want food give them the very best with
farmers dog they formulate custom meal
plans for your dogs all board certified
veterinary nutrition approved foods for
your dogs they will love them our dogs
love farmers our go to the farmers are
calm slash annejulien or click the link
down below to get 50% off every two
weeks got like hurt my brain what is
that it didn't sound right the way you
just did post meats do you wanna do it
again
no hmm ding ding thanks too late now
welcome back the music started now it's
too late now never too late it's always
on time never too late for what never
too late
always on time ok what company is that
it's known I made it up I was never too
late always on time
no never late sometimes late sometimes
late you can't cry sometimes late all
the Ducks are in here except for marble
I went from our bedroom to the podcast
room and I think he thought that I was
going downstairs so he just started
walking downstairs and he's out he he
never came back
howdy 5000 says moments like genuinely
lost right now in our house yeah he
doesn't know where we are
bobble if he comes walking in here I'll
be really happy but he's gonna come
trotting in he like he's just expecting
me to come downstairs with him I'm not
I'm not coming down I think there's a
lemon crying at you yes he is actually a
lemon like you know when you get the
defective one mm-hmm and you get to
return it for a new one yeah that's the
lemon Kermit's 11 but we call him lemon
because
mouth looks like he is a lemon mouth
because you just ate a lemon it's like
that is exactly what has my mouth looks
like but you gotta lay down I'm sorry
marble isn't here so you don't know how
to act
hey hey Kermit he like keeps all them in
line marble yeah yeah no he's he's he's
the warden no he's the Alpha
but he's the warden if this were a
prison he's the warden oh okay so yes
sick yeah in the scenario where this is
Jail his heart's beating so fast he's
like did I just wake up a hundred years
in the future or did they go in a
different room what happened he got a
news he got a new fleece he's not
wearing it but it's a very handsome new
fleece bunny bunny ate his spider-man
sure you guys speed speeder marble is no
more she didn't eat it she was chewed
about yeah she ate it but it's gone she
likes like little tiny shirts that are
my socks yeah that smell like either dog
or Julian and she wants them to be had
Thai rebel sick all right now that
marbles here's your energy gonna even
itself out Kermit he's right here
he's in his spot now you go in your spot
my Energy's not even minor my energy is
uneven Kermit I feel you dude
Yomi to even out your energy even it out
right now it's pointing up and down it's
a graph no you gotta sit okay so I had I
had an idea that it would be fun to find
brand the famous brand tag lines and
read them to you
see if you can guess the brands but even
just being here and doing a fake one
already I think it'd be funny eventually
to do an episode of faked brand taglines
where I make them up yeah I think we've
done that where we like make up our own
right yeah
but I want to do I want to do a whole
episode of me doing it so stay tuned
we're late sometimes I'm ready oops live
probably better post mates were outside
just kidding we're not just kidding we
love you post maids alright here we go
ready yeah I'm excited I feel like I'm I
do okay but not great okay so I have a
lot that are easy and then a lot that
are pretty much impossible so good luck
sick cut fun okay I'm excited that I get
to play a game because it's usually me
making the game free I know you make so
many games for me okay making games here
we go I'm gonna start with an easy one a
little softball
a little layup right high pitch just
it's gonna be floating in ready there
are some things money can't buy for
everything else there's blank see now
I'm drawing a complete blank
whoa let me do the commercial got a
voice there's some things money can't
buy for everything else there's
MasterCard MasterCard yeah high five
you're gonna upset all the littles I was
congratulating me no thank you
okay some of these are older too which
is even more interesting because they
they had like a an era of those
commercials and then they stopped okay I
watched a lot of TV in the night yeah
yeah yeah I'm ready you ready
no can you hear me now Verizon nice
thank you
stop okay the
ultimate driving machine so I think
that's obviously a car I think it's BMW
is it VW I'm really good at it pretty
good nineties commercials Blanc the
quicker picker-upper bounty not hi this
one just go you wanted yeah okay no no
okay
you're upsetting my link I'm pleased
doing important work here blank
imagination at work
sounds a little harder I also play along
at home and submit your scores through
the portal there's no portal I don't
know blank blank there's two words
imagination at work see I don't even
know what type of product yeah that
one's very imagination at work can you
give me a hint
ge ge what does GE stand for it's a
General Electric no that was the answer
it was abbreviated abbreviated Julian
you can't I'm sorry
General Electric's slogan was
imagination at work yeah cuz you imagine
things like electricity it's terrible
guess I'm thinking about right now
gen it was electricity that's so stupid
what that tagline yeah well it's like
they were trying to there's a wasp
outside our door they were trying to be
like you know we're smart people and we
have good imaginations what what are
they imagining electricity think it's
trees falling on my power line
yeah well that's imagination at work
even if it's bad imagination still at
work imagination has to go to work it
like everybody else
grind rise & grind General Electric
like a good neighbor deforms thanks
beautiful the few the proud the blank
the marine nice okay good all that
commercial a million times to the point
where I'm like I feel like it's a little
brainwashing yeah a lot of these are a
little drink machines join them I mean
that when the Marines I'm like oh my god
I mean that's wonderful and lovely for
people that do that but like you all
just make me feel constantly torn like
oh I might go to college but I want to
join the Marines
it keeps telling me I need to and want
to well that's more that's not that's a
little more prep prep to that property
no I mean like a lot of these tag lines
of just brands are like it's like
jingles on TV it's like they're made to
just like [ __ ] dig into your brain
and never leave
yeah the Marines commercials were really
cool though it's my money and I want it
now that one no it's just like a jingle
that's part of a jingle that's in my
head or whatever I'm loving it but up up
up McDonald easy dude okay this one's
taking it egg with coffee kind of egg
mcmuffin inside that style why did you
say that why did you say egg wick
warfare one time I a quick whoof I think
I was doing like a I was making a voice
and I just thought what's egg mcmuffin
upside down Egg McMuffin it's where they
take the egg and the wick Waffen the
rapid rappers on the inside it goes
[Music]
egg with weapon
egg exactly mappers right of the mill
you open the week sandwich up it's
already open but this is a rapper in the
middle you bite and you just pull
lightly one time no it's over
and then you enjoy your Anglophone
there's no enjoying an Egg McMuffin
there's only consuming it it is made for
consumption only no savoring there are
signs on the wall that say no savoring
actually uh we should I want to make
that an Egg McMuffin we're just an
inside-out Egg McMuffin it's so gross so
the the patties are egg and then there's
bread in the middle yeah no this Paul
there's you can't forget about the
packaging we'll get there
that's disgusting speaking of Egg
McMuffin
breakfast of champions Wheaties yes the
a nice in the 90s man that was good
maybe she's born with it maybe it's
Mabley okay that was good some of these
are a little in your face what's wrong
with my brain that I have all these like
brand slogans in it I don't know can I
can I erase them can I get them out I
don't want them there is there a service
that does that Kai Gil brainwipe um
leave your brainwipe recommendations in
the comments below
we're gonna wipe our brains speaking of
wipe our brains
never mind I was gonna do a Charmin
thing but I don't even know there's I
[ __ ] love waiting my ass
tik-tok me minding my own business
Charmin ultra bears
I [ __ ] love wiping my ass okay like I
said some of these are a little bit on
the nose America runs on Dunkin okay
Julian whose is that
Dona nice nice
okay don't leave home without it this is
one of those tag lines or slogans that I
don't think stuck I think it was like a
periodic mm-hmm like it only lived on
their brand campaign for like a little
period of time don't leave home without
it and it's an older it's probably
before our time but you might know it
it's a harder one can you give me a hint
that does not include the name of the
company okay
it's something if you were to purchase
this product you would literally never
like leave it it would always be with
you
there's on your person yeah it's on your
person is it a microchip no but close
sort of can give me a [ __ ] wallet noob
in your wallet is that uh like a visa is
like a visa no Discover card no keep
going
a lot of places don't take it American
Express nice okay double your pleasure
double your fun double mint gum
who makes it Wrigley's nice those
commercials were iconic and creepy but
iconic do you remember in stuck on you
oh god when they did their double bubble
commercial stuck on you because
everything is about stuck on you think
of anything in life and I will relate it
to stuck on you
that movie is a light one big life
lesson remember that they decide to sell
out and double bubble the gum company
yes they're like they do the campaign
where they're running on the beach you
can just see their bodies connected and
the brand campaign guy says we're trying
to tell people that it gives you double
the bubble not cause birth defects
I just still can't get over how one of
them is an actor pretending not telling
you it's like such a great movie one of
the best of our generation okay this
actually sounds like a slogan that I
wrote probably the best lager in the
world probably what probably the best
lager in the world
loggers like beer Oh lager
I think it's talking about like l OG ger
and almost like a logging company like
no L a ger probably the best logger in
the world it's an older campaign as well
so ah see I don't really drink beer so I
don't know what makes the lager a lager
Pale Ale does it have Pale Ale at the
end of it no damn it pretty sure this is
a English company I want to say like in
the UK uh no maybe it's Irish no I think
it's I don't [ __ ] know I'm speaking
about my but um Guinness nope
you would know for sure that that's
Irish yeah okay this is Denmark Denmark
I don't know Carlsberg Carlsberg yeah
it's the green label you ever seen those
prophets probably the best lager never
guessed that really yeah I don't drink
beer that one's kind of tough nah I'd
not be really a beer drinker you know
yeah
I'll drink it okay ready I don't know
anything about it plop plop fizz fizz oh
what a relief it is that's alka-seltzer
nice stop Travis Valley was from
nineteen
t3 well done don't stuff what happens
here stays here
Vegas Las Vegas I love how they turned
that into their own thing I know right
they took like a very like people
started saying it and then they were
like so we I want to know the
origination tourism what happens here
stays here do you think the first time
someone said that sentence it was in
regards to Vegas or do you think they
just stole it I don't know the answer to
that because it's it seems like a pretty
commonplace saying but at the same time
it could have really been from Vegas
we wouldn't know cuz it stayed there
exactly what's next we're gonna talk
about Fight Club talk about what you're
in good hands
Allstate nice why is this in my brain I
don't know see this is like more of a
display of how brainwashed Americans are
I feel brainwashed where's the beef
Wendy's what that's an old commercial
rattling these off dude your brain is
rattling these off you're not even doing
it it's just it's doing itself blank
it's everywhere you want to be I I know
what that is it's familiar I'm just
having a hard time think you know what
it is it's everywhere you is that like
visa oh my god yeah nothing but net
thank you it was visa mm-hmm you know
what's crazy what is you put your visa
credit card on your post mates account
and then when you order post mates it
just charges to it you don't have to
actually pull out your credit card every
time you have to swipe it it's just on
your account so when you're hungry and
you want a little snack or a meal and
you don't want to go out and get it you
just open the post mates app it's really
convenient all your favorite restaurants
are right in front of you the menus are
there clear beautiful pictures you
select what you want and you click order
and then guess what a wonderful person
from post mates will deliver your food
right to your front door or place of
work or wherever you might
and they say here you go here you go and
then they smile and then they're on
their way and you get to track them the
whole way on the postmates sap you see
how far they are you can message them
you have options to put modifications in
which I do kind of a lot as you know
because I don't eat like the most normal
meals because of my dietary restrictions
24 hours a day guys 365 days a year that
means on holidays during the night
during the day whatever you might be
hungry and need a meal post mates is
there for you it is so wonderful we use
it literally all the time you could post
me Thanksgiving you could post mase
Thanksgiving you actually they have a
really cool seasonal options in there so
check it out download the post mates app
use code Jenna Julianne within the app
to get $100 a free delivery credit for
your first 7 days on the app save the
hassle use Post minutes check it out
also guys intern speaking of saving
hassle get stitch fix all right if
you're looking to spruce up the old
wardrobe but you don't feel like going
out or maybe you just tried going
shopping and it's just kind of not your
thing hasn't worked out go to stitch fix
comm slash annejulien
now available in the UK and what you do
is you fill out a style profile you
answer a few questions would I wear this
what I were that yes I prefer this to
that I'm the type of person who
generally wears this and they keep this
information and they hand it to one of
their professional stylists and they
send you a box of clothes that are
styled specifically for you and then you
only keep what you like they cover the
shipping which is really convenient ok
right now when you go to stitch fix calm
slash down and Julien you get an extra
25% off when you keep everything in your
box ok it's super easy super convenient
and I've gotten actually a number of
really cool pieces of clothing that I
wear to this day from stitch fix from
someone else saying hey this would look
good on you they were right stitch fix
calm flash challenge line and lastly
guys feed your dogs what they want to be
fed with farmer's dog it is an amazing
service they provide human grade and
people tested recipes developed by board
certified veterinary nutritionists so
you know your dog is getting the right
foods and not only that they love it
they run to feeding time every single
day and night they love it they love it
they love it marble at one point had to
have Jenna sit there with him and while
he ate and now he just like Sprint's at
a hundred miles an hour towards the
kitchen and he's like
I'm [ __ ] eat no longer have to sit
with him while you no longer the food
arrives in a box and it's pre
proportioned and packaged so it's super
easy to just cut open and feed your dogs
they love it start feeding your dogs
better nay get fifty percent off your
first two week trial of fresh healthy
food at the farmer's dog calm slash
annejulien or click the link down and
below to get started
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors
for supporting us and the podcast bird
okay you ready every kiss begins with
Kay you said the name of the I had to
read the jingle who is it
okay okay what K Jewelers nice how do
you think those like those mall style
jewelers are doing in the internet age
they're still there yeah they are you
know they haven't like gone away I
wonder I mean I really do feel like
there is like a big portion of people I
want to say boomers but like you know
like our parents like older than us who
feel like at least when it comes to
jewelry
it needs a personal touch so you need to
go to a mall I mean I've been to jewelry
stores I feel completely out of place
that most of them because there's this
level of like oh hello how may I help
you
yeah child you know I'm just like I
don't [ __ ] know well you know but I
do think a lot of people might feel as
though they need to go in person to
these stores because a piece of jewelry
or a ring or whatever requires well yeah
when you're spending that much money you
want to see it you know yeah and also I
I get I get the idea of like literally
wanting to see it in person you know
buying something that expensive online
is this scary treacherous thing I feel
like for a lot of people that's what I
feel like our generation and the
generation younger than us like what
wild if we see something that we like
online we'll just buy it yeah yeah well
research we'll make sure we're buying
the right thing and then with what
without ever seeing it we're just like
yeah sure yeah that for sure like I see
a lot of Instagram ads
like jewelry companies they're fine
jewelry you know so it's like a little
expensive yeah
and people just buy it online yeah so I
was wondering I wonder how those
companies are doing since the internet
since our generation they really isn't
interested in spending a fortune on
diamonds and jewelry for sure as much as
our parents are sure that is also a very
big and B we're willing to just like buy
it off Instagram yeah I mean not only
like like Instagram ads but just online
shopping in general like think about our
our peers right and like the people our
age who shop for things they don't go to
the mall as much as we did when we were
younger
mm-hm like going to the mall was how you
purchase things gifts or otherwise and
what you did and what you did it was
like a fun thing but like now I mean
yeah sorry but it does always feel like
the oldest place in the mall not to be
mean but like there's usually somewhat
older people working there and it's like
an older crowd shopping there the rest I
mean I don't know I just feel like it's
it doesn't ever feel youthful at the
mall kay Jewelers okay I get on I'm
gonna sing the jingle but I'm gonna hum
the name of the company so you don't
know it why why are you singing it cuz I
it's not even on the list this is just
one that I know and I used to hear it a
lot okay hmm HM hmm
it's your star this isn't fair this is
just something that you remember I bet
you someone out there knows what I'm
talking about I don't know what it is
Albertsons it's your store
well that was for y'all taste the
rainbow
skittles nice you're gonna like the way
you look
I guarantee it Men's Wearhouse your
brain wha this is like all the people in
Europe are like this game sucks Yeah
right like must see you guys leave
Carlsberg was dope but what the [ __ ] is
the rest of this
all right think different just like IBM
or something or something think
different give me a hint
is it a technology company s you're very
close you're gonna get it I name any my
hints we use their products Apple yeah
Apple it's Apple I was gonna go like
this but I would have been a little too
on the nose
hmm think different from Apple got it
sick impossible is nothing you know
don't let me distract you by talking
while you're thinking give me a hit well
it is athletic based impossible is
nothing it has to do with athletics it's
not Nike or is it Nike No
do you remember the commercials
impossible is nothing it would usually
end with nevermind I've said too much
your clothes adidas yeah they were
really good commercials that was some of
like the better Apparel ad campaigning
I've seen in my in my lifetime the
impossible is nothing that was good I
don't think they have it anymore
okay the city never sleeps York no the
city never sleeps
spelled see iti City baby nice you got
it sick that's so stupid yeah Bing yeah
you literally do sleep you usually
barely close at 5:00 a.m. and on Sundays
you sleep all the time you sleep like
enough to be a hibernating bear Citibank
oh god awful so this one you better get
a
mmm good Campbell holy [ __ ] soup yeah I
was gonna say you better get it cuz
you're a soup fiend but like I didn't
even know that one yeah good yeah there
were so many commercials for Campbell's
when I was a kid and then people were
like this is nasty
why are we taking condensed soup and
mixing with water okay so this is a
repeat brand some of their soups are
soul okay so I'm not trying to rag on
Campbell's go ahead
different slogan already did this brand
I can't believe I ate the whole thing
wait wait wait I can't believe I ate the
whole thing
it's an old like McDonald's or something
like that something like that what would
you be selling to someone who said food
well I don't know alka-seltzer
that's me though I can't believe I ate
the whole thing now that I shove a pill
down my throat cuz you can you are the
only person I've ever met that can like
eat themselves sick well log I'm a man
of many talents I wear many hats
sometimes the hats just you're just like
eating and eating and eating and then
you're like oh my god I don't feel good
I'm like chewy I notice until the end
how am I supposed to notice before it
feels like that she didn't thread the
needle you guys she couldn't handle it
it keeps going and going and going
energizer nice is it in you oh my god it
was like a yellow something like a
lightning bolt there I don't know
something really stupid
she have the hiccups
peachie really cute you know baby
okay yellow lightning bolt come on take
it home you got this Gatorade yes
Gatorade is it in you
that's gross jared is it in you yeah can
you get out of me
Gatorade it's in you okay
so easy a caveman could do it Geico nice
those are great goals
those are great commercials also like
the golden era of Super Bowl commercials
when they were funny and fun and yeah
just there to entertain everyone ready
yes when you care enough to send the
very best
just like 1-800 flowers or something
damn you're so close something very
similar to flowers candy uh uh usually
accompanies flowers chocolate balloons a
card hallmark yep
yeah pardon me do you have any Grey
Poupon
Grey Poupon those are good commercial
still okay
I love Grey Poupon you do love Grey
Poupon so good Grey Poupon what stop
Julian no they're great
frosted plate nice what's his name bonus
points Tony the Tiger Tony the Tiger he
says he comes on the commercial he
doesn't say anything about frosted
flakes he's just like oh he's just
clearly in distress his rabies
the happiest place on earth
Disneyland have you been there I've been
in Disneyworld no no we need to think
you Disneyland be fun never been
Disneyland go okay tastes great less
filling sorry dear face tastes great
less filling
it's a drink
Miller Lite what uh how because I think
of something that would be good if it's
less filling beer yeah but like how did
you get smille err if you think about
food doesn't make any sense why would I
want to eat something that's less
filling no you want to be fill that's
how I am I when I'm feeling myself up I
treat it like I'm filling my car up with
gas I would love to get to the tippy top
just before it spits out there it is
spitting out gasoline all over the gas
station everyone around you is running
in fear you're acting like I vomit like
after a big meal all the time I don't
I've only don't know like maybe 3040
thousand a life but it's like it's
genuinely like he's just all of a sudden
eating too much and just realize who can
relate to that like peach and I are very
similar in that like sometimes I'll just
be so like I'm just like immersed in the
meal and the eating experience that when
I finally like like sit back and look up
I'm like I've eaten too much and then I
just have to deal with it usually I just
avoid throwing up at all cost because I
hate I hate that okay snap crackle pop
Rice Krispies good
obey your thirst it's bright bak that
that is really in great yeah it's
different
phoof Blanc that was easy
staples yep
you know it's crazy that these are just
rattled off this one's tough
I don't think you'll get this think
small
IBM there's something no how does think
big but good good try I mean don't know
Volkswagen yeah that's [ __ ] weird
guys mmm-hmm you all let me go back and
revise this we need to update this list
blank
king of beers Budweiser yep the hubris
right we're the king of beers this is a
democracy our beers live in a castle
blank have it your way
Burger King [ __ ] dude you're scary good
at this information in my brain that I
don't want like why can't i purge my
brain of the things I don't forget heard
it good when something goes in your
brain you can't get it out of your brain
that's what I'm talking about
get it out nice where a kid can be a kid
Toys R Us no is it is at the end of it
yeah I know what that is if you were a
kid you would probably enjoy going to
this place as much as Toys R Us probably
more mmm cheese yeah that was good that
was Chuckie Cheese where can be a kid
where where a kid can get a slice of
pizza made from several other slices of
pizza
thank you conspiracy blank welcome to
the human Network well I don't like that
I have a visceral accident I can see it
oh it's visual oh I don't know eighty
now Cisco Systems yeah [ __ ] that
okay don't call us a human network it
gives me the X the X yeah okay buy it
sell it love it buy it list it sell it
love it it's love it or list it or TLC
buy it sell it love it is a eBay yeah
okay sick okay I only got a few more the
best a man can get nice the best tires
in the world have blank written all over
them
Firestone no Michelin no 2019 has been a
really what are you doing what is that
2019 has been a really why did you just
shake your head at me are you okay I'm
fine I feel a little under the weather
how is this a hint
Julianne anything can go in the blank
that you just made
okay a lot of positive things happened
in 2020 nineteen was a really great good
year good year nice doesn't mean that I
was guessing tires and then you just
started shaking your head around well
I've got to play the game too okay you
guess and I shake oh the snack that
smiles back goldfish YUM
I'm gonna rename this episode to how
brainwash Jenna is this is scary I'm
scared for me quality never goes out of
style
mmm I swear if you get this one
quality never goes out of style I don't
know it's like a fashion company hmm
is it shoes no clothes hmm men's clothes
sounds like Men's Wearhouse it's it's
not just for me just for men and Jenna
no any more specific you wear them on
your legs
Dockers no Lee jeans the first part of
that word Lee that's not helpful
it absolutely is Lee that's the first
part of the word they are jeans now I
know I'm lost
Levi's Levi's nice see I was gonna get
there you said mom lost that means maybe
answered no sorry
life's good is that one of them yeah
that's the thing laughs good that was I
don't know all I can think of is that
like that brand that just says life's
good and has the happy face so that's
clouding my ability to well that is the
brand and I'm reading
it's called life's good no but it's nice
it's not called life Scott but the brand
you're describing is the one of them I
don't know it's an abbreviation hint LG
LG okay ready
this is your brain on drugs just like
anti drugs
yeah a partnership for a drug-free
America those commercials were legendary
hello all right I think that's kind of
all of them I mean there's a few in here
that I didn't even read because they're
so like obscure and it wouldn't even be
fair oh how about this finger looking
good
KFC yep the relentless pursuit of
perfection
that's like De Beers or some [ __ ]
know what it's a car company Oh
Nissan Oh No Oh Lexus
yeah something pretentious what's the
RPG the relentless pursuit of perfection
shut up Lexus shut up okay ready
what's in your wallet give it to me I
want a capital one yeah what's in your
wallet please can I see it no excuse me
miss nice to meet you it's none of your
[ __ ] business what's in your wallet
what's in your wallet
Amy what the [ __ ] is in your wallet now
show me watch over you all show me a
wall show me wallet you're upsetting
marble capital one this is a stick-up
give me your wall mm how do you think
you would have done Julie definitely
worse than you I wrong I probably have
done okay
just cuz I'm probably as brainwashed as
you but some of these are they're scary
like out of context they don't feel like
I know them but then hearing you just
like answer them is like they're they've
been around for so long and been read to
us in so many different capacities and
so we different commercials but yeah
that was I mean you did really good I
would say you got like an A I wish they
weren't taking up space in my brain
though like I wish that if I was
watching a show that I wanted to watch
yeah they didn't get space in my brain
because for however much money they paid
for the
add to be on TV when I saw it it's like
they bought that space in my brain
forever
why do they get to have that well it's
there why do they get to have that's
there you if you wanted to take up
learning a new language it'd be easier
if you didn't have that space in your
brain already taken up by LG and
Wheaties I'm not sure there's an
argument for learning as secondly we
know no easier if you were it would all
it would be brands you can learn a
second language for 10 done faster
duolingo yeah I guess kind of more this
is more interesting and like sort of
experimental than it was like a game but
it was fine what was interesting and
what was interesting and experimental
about this watching you display how much
of the real estate inside this old
noggin I feel like those are easy though
but are they though or we just are we
just in there it's just in there yeah
like we're just we're deep into it I bet
you know what I bet there's a lot of
really good um alright ready
eight seven seven cache now who's that
call one 800 800
yeah what about this one
I mean that phone number come on like
who forgets 888 okay but can you can you
can you sing the whole
freecreditreport.com song can you sing
the whole song no I [ __ ] hate that I
can can you drop me a beat real quick
drop me a beat DJ Jenna well I was
shopping for a new car which one's me a
cool convertible or an SUV too bad I
didn't know my credit was whack because
now I'm driving off hour in a new
subcompact s
fr EE that spells freecreditreport.com
baby should something on my vid be vit
that credit baby no I know other words I
hated those commercials
I thought heed that spells
freecreditreport.com baby as a great
song I mean that was just a straight-up
good song it was a good jingle good yes
it is good jingles deserve real estate
in your brain bad ones don't but they
get it anyway that was a jingle I
understand those it gets stuck in your
head but like that wasn't good the
slogans the way that they're just in my
brain really bother me yeah like this is
the words like I have nothing against a
song or something musical that you
always remember like I think that that's
smart yeah well cause it took creativity
yeah totally
but just the slogan I'm like why is that
in here get it out it's because I
literally just repeat it over and over
and over right on the radio on TV in
person like over just years it makes me
think that they were they like knew that
though like no no I mean yeah they do
but do they know that it's gonna stick
in your head forever what are they on
some [ __ ] [ __ ] were that well we were
just like oh yeah you're marketing your
product I get it all listen but really
they were like no we're [ __ ] grabbing
real estate in these people's brains
that is gonna last their entire lifetime
even way longer than this company will
last that's that's it that's my TED talk
thanks no thank you
thanks for giving it to me no problem
we're Gatorade is it in you that is so
disgusting out of context Gatorade is it
in you stop what when you say it like
that just reading I'm reading company
slogans baby this is PG content Gatorade
is it in you say Marvel Gatorade is it
in you Apple think different
alright here's like knocking things
around a little knock and lock and try
anyway I hope you guys got something out
of this I don't know a quick little
announce II boy
there's no podcast next week because of
Thanksgiving the web' machine is coming
on Tuesday we're gonna have Thanksgiving
a Webby machine what are we making
I'm gonna make stuffing in fried chicken
and you can make taters mashed potatoes
and eyes - seven cranberry sauces all to
myself
oh thank you
seven yeah well I got to go shopping for
cranberry sauce but other than that
we'll be ready I hope you guys in
America have a wonderful Thanksgiving
everyone else I hope you don't I'm sure
it's nothing Canada happened last month
it happened last night in Canada and if
you celebrate Thanksgiving from wherever
you are in the world I hope you guys
have a wonderful Thanksgiving up you're
spending it with people that you love
and eat good food and yeah so we'll take
next week off we'll be streaming
sporadically through the Thanksgiving
week though and we'll see you in a
couple weeks but yeah Happy Holidays and
uh oh my gosh next time we see you it's
gonna be December how exciting we're
gonna get festive Christmas bunnies
first Christmas Eve Oh bunny Claus I
take marble shirts and eat them I take I
bunny take I Santa but instead of give I
take all right guys see you on the next
one
[Music]
[Music]